In today's video,
we're going to put
something to test
that a lot of you may have been
curious about at some point.
Can a flamethrower be used
to clear away snow?
[Music]
Guys, we've made flamethrowers.
A lot of flamethrowers.
Several different types
of flamethrowers in the past,
and today, we've got
three of them here.
We're going to test them all.
I've had to shovel
my driveway several times
in the last few weeks,
and I hate it.
Every time I do it,
i just wonder like,
would it be better to just try
and melt it all away?
So we're up here the dome,
and there's snow all
around this dome,
and we have flamethrowers.
We do.
So we're going to test them out.
We've got three,
we've got our fire
extinguisher flamethrower,
which can use a powder
or a liquid fuel.
We're going to be
using liquid today.
We've got our
arm-mounted flamethrower,
which uses canisters
of propane as a fuel.
And then we've got Big Bertha,
the first flame thrower actually
that Grant built,
and this uses gasoline
and diesel as a fuel.
So while I think the biggest one
is going to work the best,
I gotta say I'm
not super confident
that any of them are going
to clear much of the snow.
But we still have to know.
We really want to try.
Yeah.
And I think that no matter
how poorly it performs,
it's going to be so much
more fun than shoveling snow.
So true.
Shoveling snow isn't fun.
Here's the basic idea.
You have seen us use
or create several
flamethrowers in the past.
Now, we're going to go ahead
and take these flamethrowers,
and put it to the test
against the snow.
Okay.
My first question though is,
how effective do you
think this is going to be,
and which one do you think
is going to work best?
I'll answer your questions
in reverse order.
Which one is going to work best?
I think that the big one
is going to work best,
because that actually
sprays out fuel.
It sprays it out,
and sometimes, that fuel
can even land on stuff
and keep burning.
As for how effective
it's going to be though,
I'm really not sure.
Flamethrowers put out
a lot of heat.
They do, but not for
an extended amount of time.
It's true.
I think the longest
running one is the big one,
and we only get maybe
a minute out of that.
Maybe this one goes
a little bit longer,
with it's propane tanks
because it's not pouring
fuel as quickly.
Let's start with the little one.
Let's go.
[Music]
How to clear
your driveway, test 1.
I think it just went out.
No, it was burning something.
Was it?
Yeah.
Well, my arms' on fire.
So there's that.
Yeah, I couldn't
really see anything,
but you can see the marks.
So, first test didn't go
according to plan.
We think there's probably
just a little too much liquid
in the canister.
So we've added some boric acid.
That's going to make
our flames green
so we can hopefully at least
see the flame hitting the snow,
especially with how bright
it is right now.
I'm also going to try
and pressurize it
just a little bit more
so it's spraying out,
and like aerosolizing more
than it did last time.
Okay.
There goes nothing.
Yeah.
Dang it.
It blew it out.
All right, we're gonna try
one more time with
what we've got left.
But you can see the green flame.
You can see it's not done
much to the snow.
It's pockmarked it a little bit,
but that's about it.
It wasn't very visible.
So we've actually
shovelled a couple
of snow inside the dome
so we can make it darker,
and we're going to try
this just one more time
before moving on
to our next flamethrower.
So guys, we're testing this
because I wanted
to not shovel snow,
and then here I
am, shoveling snow.
Well, it didn't do
anything to the snow,
but it made me very happy.
So amazingly,
that's like the exact same thing
that was happening outside.
Yeah.
>> You just couldn't see it outside.
>> You couldn't see it.
Methanol burns
very light colored.
Like compared to color
that the lighter fluid burns,
it's almost invisible.
Like you can--
There's a lot of it
on the ground,
still right here.
This is all on fire,
but it's almost all methanol.
And so it's just
almost invisible,
even with the green in it.
[Music]
All right, here it goes.
We're going to do a test.
See if we can get it
to ignite with the taser.
If that doesn't work,
we're going to go
to our little fire sticks,
but here it goes.
Ready and...
Now, that was considerably more
effective than the methanol.
Just slightly.
[Music]
That got rid of that lump
of snow pretty quick.
I think we need to do it again,
but outside and see how much
we can actually clear away.
That was about
one shovel full of like--
With a normal snow shovel
clearing my driveway,
that was about one shovelful.
So, it still take several hours,
but you could do it.
But it got rid of it.
It did.
In this situation.
All right, let's refuel.
Try it outside.
[Music]
Well...
Wow.
You put a hole in the snow.
I think that was already there.
It worked a lot better inside
when it was just a pile
of snow surrounded by dirt.
With the snow
surrounded by more snow,
it was even less effective.
Yeah, it's true.
The surface is now slush.
Yeah.
That's about as
far as we've got.
I think I've dropped
down about an inch,
and that was it.
Whole double tanks of propane.
Oh, maybe it wasn't.
Oh, that was only one tank.
That's one.
Oh.
Let's relight.
All right.
That's one tank.
One more to go.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
All right, that's a decent dent.
I mean, kind of.
It is a decent then
given the fact
that it's 14 degrees,
and we have
several feet of snow.
So that's now both tanks
worth of fuel emptied down
onto it, and that's,
that's not much.
I think it's still more
than we were expecting to do,
especially after the fire
extinguisher flamethrower.
That's true.
The fire extinguisher really
got pretty much nowhere.
This at least like
visibly melted some snow.
It's also softer,
like this is very hard
and frozen snow right now.
This is slushy now.
We've made a slush surface,
and we made it dirty too.
It's nice and clean underneath,
but more melted.
Yeah.
[Music]
So yeah, I don't think
this this particular one
would be good for cleaning
off your driveway,
but car windshield maybe.
If you really really don't care
about your car's paint job.
All right, I think
it's time for Big Bertha.
[Music]
Guys, I've never gotten
to play with Big Bertha
before so I'm thrilled.
I'm also thrilled
that Nate is holding that fire
extinguisher in his hand.
A real one.
All right.
Yes.
[Music]
Wooh!
I think it works.
I love this thing.
[Music]
I think that one is
the most successful so far.
It might not be the most
practical or effective way
of clearing snow
off your driveway,
but I think we can all agree
that it's the most fun.
That's just the look
of pure glee on my face.
That pretty much sums up
how I felt at the time.
Pretty much the result of using
flamethrowers in my experience.
So of the three.
Yep.
Fire extinguisher with methanol.
Pretty much worthless.
Yeah.
I'm going to go and say
that does nothing.
Slightly stained the snow,
and that was
about the end of it.
Propane mounted flamethrower.
Decent.
Surprisingly good.
>> In small quantity.
>> Especially in small quantities.
Yes.
Out in the snow
on the driveway, not great.
But I think it actually melted
about the same amount
of snow as the big one
that was using diesel
and gasoline as a fuel.
The only advantage I am seeing
to our diesel and gasoline
flamethrower, Big Bertha,
is that the fuel
itself is being ejected
with the flame itself,
so it's landing
and still burning,
so you have a little
bit more burn time.
That's about it.
Overall, I'm gonna say
this doesn't work.
It's very fun.
But it is not very effective.
This is why we use shovels.
It's just takes too
much energy to melt snow.
Guys, that's not all.
You know we've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you to our latest video,
and that box at the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit this bomb in the middle
to subscribe to the club
so you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and I'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.